hey you guys happy thanksgiving out
there if you're celebrating it i hope
that you're having a good one
and uh since this is thursday and
thursday is my usual day to upload
flickers of fear i thought to myself
self why don't you do kind of a new
thanksgiving movie now i will say that
thanksgiving is kind of like there are
some thanksgiving themed horror movies
i'm not saying there's not
but
i kind of feel like you know
there's so many christmas ones and
there's somebody like even other
holidays like have a bunch of ones
thanksgiving kind of like gets
sort of swept under the rug it doesn't
really get as many as some of the other
holidays and honestly even some of the
movies that come up because i actually
did check like you know some lists of
thanksgiving horror movies and probably
about half of the ones that came out
were
horror movies that just happened to be
set on thanksgiving but didn't really
have anything to do with thanksgiving so
there's that whole thing too uh like i
said there are a few there's thanks
killing which obviously we uh we
reviewed earlier this week there's blood
rage which again i think is more like
set at thanksgiving there's one called
poultry geist which
should give you an idea uh but you know
so there's something like that uh
there's actually i'd actually like to
make a recommendation there's a movie
called christy
which
is set at thanksgiving again but it's
not necessarily about thanksgiving but
it's still like a really really good uh
it's still a really good horror movie so
i would recommend that as well
so there are some
but not a great deal and there was even
i think it was a 2016.
there was a horror anthology movie
called holidays which i don't know is it
on netflix i feel like i watched it on
netflix they had it was kind of like a
different segment for each holiday they
had like st patrick's day they had
mother's day they had christmas they had
new years then all this other kind of
stuff but even that movie didn't even
have a thanksgiving segment so that's
how
out of it that's how like nobody wants
to make and like i said there's the
whole you know from grindhouse uh eli
roth made that fake trailer for the
thanksgiving horror movie which i kind
of wish you would make in real life
because it looks like really awesome but
uh yeah so not really that's kind of
like slim pickings like i said and we
already did thanks killing and i wanted
one that was kind of like newer
so then i thought to myself well hulu if
you don't have uh hulu
they have actually partnered with
blumhouse
and what they do is they have they call
it a horror anthology series even though
technically it's just like a set of
movies and it's called into the dark
and it's been going since i think 2018
and they do it in seasons even though
the movies are not really interrelated
uh in any way they put out a movie once
every month
and usually the movie has something to
do with whatever holiday is going on in
that month sometimes
overtly sometimes just kind of like as
an afterthought or like tangentially
some of them it's like a lot of them
seem to be
have gotten kind of like middling
reviews from people
i have seen the only one that i've seen
i went through the wikipedia page and
like flipped through there the only one
i've seen is actually the christmas
themed one that came out last christmas
and i think we talked about it on our
matinee show and that was called puka
that one was actually really really good
i had a good time with that one and fun
fact in this horror movie that i'm
talking about today the thanksgiving one
there is a little easter egg where
there's actually a pooka doll that shows
up like in the background of one of the
kids rooms which i thought was very
amusing but some of the other ones like
i said some of them seem like they have
because they actually did do into the
dark actually did do a thanksgiving
movie
back in 2018 and it was called flesh and
blood and i haven't seen that one but i
read the plot synopsis just to see if
that was maybe one that i wanted to do
and it seemed more like
one again that was just like set on
thanksgiving rather than actually being
about thanksgiving
so i decided instead to do one that
looked a lot more thanksgivingy uh which
was pilgrim which came out in 2019 so
that's 2019's uh you know into the dark
for thanksgiving for november so that's
when it came out and they and they drop
them i think like the first of every
month so this came out like november 1st
2019 and i gotta say yeah if you were
looking for like a really thanksgiving a
thanksgiving movie this is this should
definitely be your cup of tea i had i
kind of i i tried to get like a sampling
of what people like thought of it
it seemed like it got like a lot of
critical response uh that it was
actually like really good and really fun
it's a very outlandish premise but in a
way i think that kind of works in its
favor and also i kind of like the way
like the last act of it just went balls
to the wall just like that [ __ ] insane
and i thought that was also like a
really good choice because what i've
heard
like i said i loved puka uh that was a
great one that was a christmas one they
actually did a
sequel to that but i haven't watched it
yet even though i will get around to it
because i really did like the first one
a lot but one main criticism that i
heard of a lot of the earlier into the
dark movies was that you know this is
you know you're going right to hulu you
can make pretty much whatever you want
as long as it has to do with that
holiday or that month or whatever and it
should be like more of an excuse for
filmmakers to just go crazy with it and
i kind of feel like a lot of people
thought that maybe
the filmmakers weren't doing that they
were like playing it too safe or like
the movies were just kind of like okay
um but this one seemed to have gotten a
lot more positive response although i
did see some like
just random viewer reviews of like
people that hated it but a lot of
critics seem to like it and i would have
to agree i don't like it quite as much
as puka but
it's like i said this one's like a lot
of fun i thought it was like a good like
the build up is kind of slow but i liked
that because like the build up it was
kind of creepy i mean you kind of
knew like how it was gonna go or you
know that [ __ ] was gonna go bad
obviously but i like that they kind of
like played around with you weren't
entirely sure
like what the situation was and like how
it was gonna go exactly so i think that
that was good that they had a good job
like you know building up suspense and
everything like that and then like the
last half just goes like gory [ __ ] uh
so like i said if if you're real
squeamish about gore this again might
not be one for you because even though
it's kind of a slow burn leading up to
that like in the last act it just gets
the [ __ ] crazy and there's just like
blood and vomit and [ __ ] like that like
spraying everywhere so you might not
like want to watch that
so uh this was actually co-written and
directed
by marcus dunstan
who also did uh the collector movies the
collector the collection i think they're
uh doing another one called the
collected or something like that but i
don't think it's come out yet uh those
are also really good um if you haven't
seen those
and uh the other writer on it was noah
feinberg and then there was another guy
patrick melton who was also i believe a
co-writer on scary stories to tell in
the dark uh he did some of the saw
movies like four five six and seven i
think and uh also piranha three double d
so you know there's there's that as well
but so these you know see these are guys
that like
you know know what they're doing they
they've worked on the saw movies and
[ __ ] like that so you're you're getting
uh you know guys that are kind of like
well regarded in the horror community
largely so what we have uh with this
movie here pilgrim
there's a family the baker family now
this is kind of like a blended family in
the sense that the older daughter whose
name is cody she's actually played by
rayne edwards and like the whole time i
was watching the movie i'm like god damn
why is she so [ __ ] familiar i must
have seen her in something else and then
when i looked up her imdb she was in
hellfest so which we actually saw in the
theater when it came out and i've seen
it like once since then i was like oh
okay well that's why that explains that
that's where i saw her before she was in
hell fast among other things
so she's like an older stepdaughter
she's like kind of like college age so i
guess she's like home for thanksgiving
like from college and uh she doesn't get
along too well with her dad's
new wife like i don't know how long
they've been married it seems like it's
been a while but not like a really long
time so she also has a thing where
her mom uh and her dad like her mom left
on thanksgiving and basically like left
her there with the dad when she was a
kid and then the dad remarried and uh
subsequently the dad and the stepmom
have had another have had another kid
which is like a little uh a little boy
who is actually like pretty cute and the
the two of them like actually really do
get along like cody really does love her
little uh brother
but she doesn't get along with her
stepmom anna too much she was actually
played by uh courtney hengiller hengler
i guess is how you pronounce her last
name who again very familiar and then i
was like oh yeah she's
daniel she's daniel's wife in
cobra kai so that's where i'd seen her
before she's been at a bunch of other
[ __ ] too but that's just where i've seen
her most recently because i really like
cobra kai
so uh so they're in this family and then
the dad
who is kind of like he's some kind of
vague uh you know
stock market type dude and so he's just
constantly like on his tablet or on his
phone like checking the stock prices and
just fluctuation and everything and just
kind of like yeah whatever honey blah
blah blah and like not really like
interested
so the thing about anna the stepmom
is that she's kind of one of those and i
think they even make like
cody even makes like a stepford wives
kind of like uh joke about the whole
situation
i guess anna is one of those people
that's like really really concerned
with how like her image so she kind of
wants her family to look like the
perfect family
so she kind of like so she invites like
all the other women over like it's what
is it the pta or the no it's the hoa so
there's like this big party and she's
like super super
worried about you know how she looks and
like she's very like she seems like they
kind of imply that her life is really
curated like on her instagram and
everything like everything has to look
exactly perfect and uh she has these big
parties and everything's exactly perfect
uh but the other ladies like you kind of
like hear them snarking about it behind
her back like they know that that's not
the case but you know what i mean so
it's this kind of whole thing where she
thinks that she has to project this
perfect family type of thing but
obviously her real family is really not
like that like i said dad is kind of
like checked out he never pays attention
or listens or anything like that and her
and her
stepdaughter cody are really kind of i
mean cody is just i kind of feel like
that is maybe one thing that people
thought was um you know
what you know it was kind of a criticism
that a lot of people had about it was
that cody
is
not a super likable character but i
don't know i didn't find her unlikable
it's just that she's very you know like
older teenagers she's very like
sarcastic and she's very snotty
and but you can like understand why
she's coming like where she's coming
from so i didn't find her particularly
unlikable but you know maybe some would
you know your mileage may vary i'm not
really sure uh and honestly like in a
lot of her feelings she's kind of like
justified like in the way she feels so
it's didn't really bother me all that
much so her and her stepmom are just
constantly
uh you know locking horns with one
another and uh the poor little kid the
little boy whose name is tate he's a
very happy go lucky kind of kid and like
i said him and cody like get along
really well but he's kind of like caught
in the middle whereas like i said the
dad is just kind of like checked out and
doesn't seem to give a crap about
anything uh because he's just too busy
looking at his phone all the time
so into this like i said because anna
has this thing where she thinks oh our
family's so disconnected everybody just
stares at their phones all the time and
we don't really communicate and we don't
get along
so she decides that what she's gonna do
she finds this flyer or something like
that like online or whatever
and it's this supposedly this thing like
a thanksgiving experience and what it is
ostensibly
is that you have a bunch of people
that are like cosplaying as pilgrims and
they're supposed to come to your house
and
make thanksgiving dinner for you and
then they're like they're supposed to
like reenact like the first thanksgiving
and it's supposed to be like this really
like this bonding experience they're
gonna come and they're gonna like churn
butter and they're gonna make everything
from scratch just like they made it back
in the 1600s and it's going to be this
amazing thing and she's talking about
how there was like all these yelp
reviews and everybody's talking about
how amazing it was and it's just like oh
my god it brought our family close
together as a family and it's like it
was so wonderful and blah blah blah so
she decides she's gonna do this
now
like i said the dad is just kind of like
whatever uh the little kid's like oh
that sounds like fun cody is like this
sounds like the stupidest idea ever and
i'm like yes cody i agree this does
sound like a very stupid idea letting a
whole bunch of like strangers into your
house on a pretty important like
family-centric holiday to kind of like
trample through your house and do
whatever the [ __ ] they're gonna do
so what ends up happening though is that
so like i said a few days before
thanksgiving she's actually hosting
another party for like the the hoa the
housing uh you know and uh the
homeowners association rather and uh so
she's having a party like that so
there's like tons of people in the house
and these two
pilgrims show up on her doorstep
and she's kind of like what
you guys are kind of like a few days
early i thought you were just supposed
to come on thanksgiving and do this
whole thing
uh so the guy is named ethan and he's
played by peter giles giles giles not
really sure and uh the woman is named
patience and she's played by elise
levesque she's great uh honestly
so the two of them show up and they're
very um you know they have all the
period costume on and they are very like
they come across just like they stepped
out of the 1600s and they do not break
character ever so they are able to they
seem weird but you know nice and like
sort of
so
anna is kind of able to let herself get
talked into
okay well the pilgrims can come in here
and i guess you can stay for a few days
like in the guest room
and then like on thanksgiving they're
supposed to have this big thing with all
these pilgrims now patience actually
goes and stays with their neighbor and
the neighbor is kind of like a single
mom and then her son
and cody like the stepdaughter they kind
of have a thing like they have a romance
going
so there's that kind of whole dynamic
into it too and sometimes like he sneaks
over and like into her room and whatnot
so ethan the the male pilgrim is staying
in the main house and then patience is
staying over the other house so you kind
of jump back and forth but it's mainly
based around like the baker family and
ethan now like i said pretty much from
the jump
cody is just like suspicious of this
whole [ __ ] because it is a very
suspicious situation she's like the dude
is
does not break character like i said so
he comes across very much like an old
school like puritan type of guy
uh and he's just he kind of talks like
that he talks like in very old-fashioned
type stuff and he's just going on and on
about thanksgiving and how it means
gratitude and it's just kind of like you
know our
you know our kind of whole thing is we
want people to appreciate what they have
and yada yada
and it almost kind of seems like in his
interactions with patients it's you get
this idea that
patience is almost kind of like a cult
member sort of like because the way she
talks about him like she's always kind
of like i was ungrateful for things too
until i met ethan and then everything
was so it's almost like kind of like
it's like really really creepy so crazy
[ __ ] starts happening like like really
like sinister kind of stuff where you
know like for example like one night
cody goes into little uh you know her
little brother tate's room and even
though he's only he's probably like
eight or nine i can't really tell how
old he is but he's like a cute little
kid with glasses on and uh she goes in
there and like ethan the pilgrim is like
laying on his bed like telling him a
story and it's like it's innocent but
she's just kind of like yeah no this is
not
cool like get the [ __ ] out of my
brother's room uh you know so it's just
kind of creepy because we don't know
this guy right and it's he's supposedly
an actor or like a rent fair kind of
person or whatever and are you they're
just coming and cosplaying as pilgrims
and it's like super weird and so the
guys so the pilgrims start to get like
more and more invasive uh to a point
where you know it's implied that they're
going through everybody's stuff they're
kind of like
taking out the light bulbs and they're
putting in like lanterns and candles so
it'll be more like a more like a 1600s
type of experience it's that kind of
thing and um then he does like one of
the scenes in the early part of the
movie that made me laugh out loud is
that cody comes home like from wherever
she was at and um in their backyard like
ethan has built essentially like a
little shed like a little 1600s kind of
[ __ ] he's just like built in their in
their backyard so the point they're
making here is these pilgrims have
basically come into this house of people
that they think are like disconnected
and not grateful for what they have and
it basically essentially colonized it is
what they're doing so this is like like
i said the metaphor for i mean they do
have a thing like a scene very near the
beginning where cody says something like
oh yeah we're celebrating like you know
the the puritans coming over like
massacring the native americans or
whatever so it's like they do have
something like that but but it's almost
it's not like super heavy-handed with it
in the sense that you just have all
these pilgrims like showing up and then
all of a sudden they're like oh we're
just gonna like take over your whole
[ __ ] and it's just like i don't know
it's like it's kind of funny but that
the thing about where she took when she
comes home and like sees
that it's like built to fight a legit
[ __ ] shed like out of wood and
everything like on their pool deck and
then she takes a picture of it she's
like this pilgrim just raised a shed in
my backyard what the [ __ ] and it's just
kind of like i don't know that like
really baby laugh so but uh as obviously
uh cody is proven to be right because
uh as time goes on like i said it's not
super spoiler because you know something
bad's gonna happen you know that these
pilgrims are like up to no good so as it
goes on like more and more of the
pilgrims show up
uh at which point they're like yeah now
it's it's getting closer to actual
thanksgiving day so all of these other
strangers are like showing up in the
house that are all like these
dower-faced puritans and they're all
like shucking corn in the kitchen and
everything and at this point it's funny
because even though the dad
he didn't really seem to give a [ __ ] one
way or the other about this whole
thanksgiving experience situation that
his wife like kind of got them into
but
he seems sort of mollified because some
of the other male pilgrims show up and
they're like oh we're gonna help you
like build this garage and you can put a
bar in it so he's just like oh okay
sweet that's like that's pretty cool
that's like part of it all right so he
just kind of goes along and anna
the stepmom it's like she's starting to
get like weirded out because she's like
now all these people are in my [ __ ]
house it's like i didn't know that
that's this is how it was gonna go down
but she's still like reluctant
to just tell him to [ __ ] off even though
cody is like this is really weird and
it's like why is this even happening so
it's all this other kind of stuff so
like i said as it goes on
[ __ ] gets like worse and worse and worse
and like i said what you're left with is
there's all these pilgrims i don't they
never really say because you're just led
to assume that this is some kind of
they're not they're not like
supernatural or anything like that so
don't like get into that but it's almost
kind of like i wasn't sure
if they were saying that they were
actual appearance that they'd like like
they came forward through time or
something like that but i guess not i
don't i don't really think that that was
uh what they were getting at i think
this is just like a really like a creepy
like cult of people essentially whose
whole thing is they want to come
and invade your house and because they
think that you're not grateful enough
for stuff and if you don't show like a
sufficient amount of gratitude for what
you have or what they're giving to you
then you're gonna like be really sorry
about it like i said i don't want to
spoil too much of it but i will say the
third act of this gets like pretty bad
[ __ ] it's an outrageous premise because
like if this actually did happen even if
you did i mean that's not that weird
there might be some kind of like cosplay
like oh neat like all the pilgrims will
like show up at your house and like make
your dinner and stuff that's not that
crazy but the fact that they would just
keep encroaching like and building [ __ ]
in your backyard and stuff and you'd be
like nah get the [ __ ] out of here i'm
gonna call the cops like nobody calls
the cops uh which seems a little
which seems a little uh unbelievable but
because this the premise is kind of a
little bit outrageous or ridiculous the
movie does something good in the sense
that they're like we're just gonna lean
into it and we're just gonna go crazy
like in the third act so it's the third
act is just like gore
and like i said just spraying vomit and
poison and just all kind of crazy [ __ ]
you know stocks and dunking stools and
like the whole [ __ ] nine yards so
they just like leaned right into it and
i think that that was really um but that
was like a really good decision so like
i said if you really want to watch a
thanksgiving horror movie
that is very very thanksgivingy then
this is the most thanksgiving
thanksgiving horror movie i've ever seen
i mean it is based the whole thing is
based around
thanksgiving dinner the whole thing is
based around the idea of gratitude and
the pilgrims and you know like i said
them colonizing this these
suburbanites house and i'm doing all
this kind of like 1600s type of [ __ ] to
them and it's just kind of like so
uh but yeah this i found this one like i
said i didn't like it quite as much as
puka even though that's like a totally
different kind of movie this one i it's
still it's a lot of fun though like i
said it's the the first like two-thirds
of it are more like a slow build up and
are not really gory because like i said
this these pilgrims show up and you're
not like you know that their intentions
are bad but you're not entirely sure
what their deal is like you're like is
this a cult are they
supernatural are they what do they want
from us you know it's and then like more
of them start showing up and it's just
like this crazy kind of [ __ ] uh so yeah
so the first two thirds is like a slow
build and then it just goes into like
this sort of like
just really really gory like over the
top i wouldn't call it a horror comedy
but it does have a lot of funny stuff in
it and like i said it does kind of like
lean into how crazy the whole premise is
how like how this was allowed to happen
because nobody really stepped in other
than cody and said hey this is [ __ ] up
um and just like nobody listens to her
until it's like too late
because she knew something was up like
as soon as they turned up in the house
it's like i said it's a pretty weird the
whole situation is like pretty weird and
i have to give a shout out to like i
said the the two uh actors that play the
original two pilgrims ethan and patience
who are peter giles or giles
and uh elise levesque those two are
great like i like that ethan he's kind
of like
sort of nice but then he's like really
really sinister i mean he's pretty much
sinister like right from the get-go um
but then in the third act he just goes
like full-on like maniac and he's just
kind of like laughing and maniacally and
[ __ ] like a like a [ __ ] crazy ass
like preacher or some [ __ ] and uh
patience
is kind of like
she's almost i almost wanted to say she
was like a cyborg but she's kind of
she's very very expressionless and she's
really kind of like
she's very very creepy she's like almost
like robotic in the sense that so i
guess she's kind of like a true believer
because they don't really like i said
they don't explain like where these
pilgrims came from because what ends up
happening at one point is that anna the
step mom said oh i heard all about him
online like so there was yelp reviews
and stuff but then when they show up
cody like tries to like find their
website or something like that she's
like look my mom said they that you know
she found them online and i can't find
anything like referring to them so
so there's that kind of whole thing too
you're not really entirely sure like
where they came from
or where anna initially heard about them
but like i said it's not really it
doesn't really matter because you know
it's just like a fun
gory like thanksgiving movie and
honestly you know it's there are so few
thanksgiving movies that if you really
want to get into the food i guess
although it might kind of like
put you off your food like the end part
of it because the end of it's kind of
gross but um not it's not the grossest
thing i've ever seen but it does have
some gross [ __ ] in it like i said i just
had a really good time with it uh it's
kind of creepy it's kind of funny kind
of gory and it's very very very very
very thanksgivingy so if you i if you
don't have hulu i'm not really sure
where you can see it i think i think
it's um the into the dark movies are
hulu exclusives so i'm not entirely sure
if you can stream it anywhere if you
don't have hulu honestly like i said
this one you know seemed really good i
i've heard that some of the other into
the dark ones are kind of meh you know
whenever relevant holiday comes up i
might like check some of them out if
they get like good reviews this one
seems to have like fairly good reviews
and like i said puka i think is the best
one or at least that's the one that i
liked the most but i've only seen a
couple of these um but puka seems to be
like the favorite uh even like among
other people that have reviewed it uh so
you can watch that one for christmas
because that one's super fun
but yeah this is a perfectly good
uh entry into the thanksgiving horror
series and like i said probably the most
thanksgiving one i've ever seen so if
you want something new it's only a
couple of years old and uh very
thanksgivingy and gory and horror and
stuff like that then you could certainly
do worse than watching pilgrim on hulu
so if you've seen it
and you liked it or you didn't like it
or whatever
let me know in the comments and have a
happy thanksgiving everybody if you're
celebrating it hope you're having a good
one as i said and i will see you guys on
the next one bye